hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're gonna go over how
to conduct a most probable number test
so a most probable number test or MPN is
sometimes because of how the method is
referred to at the NPN method this is a
method that is used to count bacteria to
measure the amount of bacteria in a
sample and it is ideal for estimating
the number of microbes and very dilute
samples so when we say dilute very
dilute samples we need samples where the
bacteria are not very concentrated so
we're not talking about lab plates or or
lab cultures where you can do a plate
count or an optical density these are
samples where there are much fewer
bacteria present or at least that's what
you suspect an example of this would be
various kinds of water and food testing
so for example testing certain kinds of
water sources for coliform bacteria
coliform bacteria are bacteria that can
ferment lactose and we have a lot of
coliform bacteria in human feces and so
if there's coliforms and water that's
typically indicative of fecal
contamination so the way the MPN method
works is it uses changes in either color
of broth or changes in termina tea
that's the cloudiness that you see when
bacteria are growing in liquid culture
so it looks for either color change or
turbidity change to detect bacterial
growth
and then you look at how many tubes
either changed color or have noted
turbidity and you can count those tubes
and then interpret your results by
comparing your results to a standard
reference table and we'll go over an
example of that in a second
but when you are using the standard
reference table it's important that you
realize that the reference table will
give you a number a most probable number
an NPN and then an NPN is equal to 1 CF
u CF U is a common way of referring to
bacteria and it stands for colony
forming unit and basically that just
means one viable cell so just to recap
this method gives you a number a most
probable number for how many bacteria
are in a certain sample and that equates
to one colony forming unit which is the
same thing as saying one viable cell so
one living cell once all that's capable
of reproducing so let's go through an
example first you have your inoculation
and so in this example I'm looking at a
water sample perhaps it's from a pond
perhaps it's from look of recreational
swimming area perhaps it's a drinking
water sample we have some water sample
here and then we have three sets of five
lactose broth tubes and remember that in
this example we're looking for coliform
bacteria and coliform bacteria can
ferment lactose you could do this method
with other kinds of tests where you're
looking for a different kind of color
change or a different growth in
turbidity and different kinds of broth
depending on the type
bacteria you're looking at so here we
have our three sets of five lactose
brought tubes and what we do is we take
ten milliliters from the drinking water
sample and inoculate each of these five
- so ten milliliters added to each one
then we take one milliliter of the water
sample and add it to each of these tubes
and then we take 0.1 milliliters of
water from sample and add it to each of
these tubes and so we're having this
tenfold decrease each time in the amount
of water that's being added and so
theoretically in the amount of viable
coliforms that are being added to these
tubes then we incubate overnight at 37
degrees typically you want to incubate
for like 24 hours for this particular
method then it's time to read results
and what that means is you're looking
for the color change so when coliform
bacteria are present in these broth
tubes they will ferment the lactose and
that results in a color change and so
for this particular test we have four
positive tubes here so four of them sort
of color change one did not we have
three positive tubes here three showed a
color change - did not and then where we
were adding the smallest amount of the
water sample we've just got one positive
tube so one changed color and four did
not and so that is our results that we
then want to come and compare in the
reference table so our pattern if you
will was four three one and so we look
at our reference table if you're a
student this is often in the back of a
textbook we're gonna or in the back of
them like a lab manual so you look for
the pattern of four three one and this
tells you that if you see the four three
one pattern the MPS
the most probable number of coliforms in
the original sample was 33 per 100 mils
now if we have gotten different patterns
up here if it had been you know four for
one or if it had been five to one
different patterns will result in a
different most probable number but with
this pattern of four three and one the
best answer statistically is that for
every 100 milliliters of that sample we
have three Cup we have 33 coliform
bacteria the table also gives us a
confidence for a 95% confidence range
and for the pattern for 3-1 the 95%
confidence range is 11 to 93 so the most
probable number is 11 to 90 per 100
milliliters and all this means is that
whereas 33 is like the best gas the most
sort of statistically supported gas you
can be 95% confident that in this water
sample that gave this pattern there is
somewhere between 11 and 93 viable
coliform bacteria per 100 mils of this
sample so that is how you conduct an NPN
test if you want to learn more about
bacterial growth you can check out my
video on bacterial growth curves and
binary fission but that's it for today
thanks for watching biology professor